Kathy Wood is the founder CEO and CIO of
Arc Investment Management this
conversation was recorded at a live
event lyceum Miami which occurred on
March 4th at the Miami Beach Convention
Center I really enjoyed this
conversation with Kathy and I think you
will too here's my conversation with
Kathy Wood you are known
for Innovation and investing in
Innovation I thought a great place to
start would just be how do you think
about what is innovation and what makes
a company Innovative versus maybe just a
company that is surviving and kind of
going through the motions
okay so uh our Innovation platforms are
all technologically enabled which means
they follow learning curves and learning
curves are expressed or characterized by
cost declines so they're very
deflationary but it's a good deflation
so the first characteristic is learning
curves cost declines if you've heard of
rights law Wright's law is a relative of
Moore's Law we've centered our research
on that and we can figure out how
quickly costs will fall and how much
demand is likely to take off as more and
more sectors
gain access to these Technologies so
that's the first the second is that
these Technologies or the platforms
scale across sectors so we've set up our
research at ARC very differently from
traditional Asset Management our analyst
responsibilities are broken out by
technology and there are 14 different
Technologies involved in the five
Innovation platforms so they are Tech
Specialists and sector generalists it's
the flip side of how research is
organized traditionally and then the
third characteristic is they are
launching pads for new innovation so in
the case of what we now call multi-ohmic
screening used to call it genomic
screening if we had not figured out DNA
sequencing specifically so that we could
analyze the six billion bits of code in
our genomes we would never have been
able to isolate mutations mutations are
the earliest manifestation of disease so
that was sequencing and because of that
an innovation called Gene editing was
possible if you can isolate a mutation
you can reprogram it edit it out so
we're seeing incredible uh results cures
for disease and we think that's going to
become a big theme in the years ahead so
one of the pieces of this thematic
investing that you're doing that I don't
think people quite understand is that
historically where that money came from
and how the actual funding occurred
um wasn't in a traditional model so
Venture Capital as one example is kind
of this Milestone based funding where
somebody would say hey I'll give you a
little bit of money make progress come
back I'll give you some more money make
progress come back maybe more money how
do you think about funding and both the
capital Source but also the capital
mechanism of the investment for
Innovation versus you know a company
that's been around for 100 years and
kind of is just throwing off profit okay
so that's a big question so there's
private and there's public the private
is of course the venture capital and
because of our tax laws here in the
United States and the preferential
treatment for private equity and carried
interest specifically
Venture Capital has really become
isolated I would say to you know those
with very high incomes or assets
and and the little guy or the average
investor or even some foundations and
institutions cannot get into these deals
it's a very small circle here and so
we're trying to do there what we did in
the ETF space in the ETF space we've
turned what was a passive rapper rapper
is just just how you deliver a fund
called the ETF into an active wrapper
and most people thought we were crazy
which I love I love when people think
we're crazy if we're on to something and
so at first we were again ignored by the
industry and now everyone nine years
later
understands this is the better better
model for the End customer
in the private world what we're doing is
we're taking something called an
interval fund and an interval fund that
concept evolved in the 90s believe it or
not just like the ETFs and here the SEC
was trying
to give individual investors access to
private deals uh now why didn't that
happen well it happened did not happen
because of the preferential tax
treatment for this accredited investor
strategy uh so we cannot charge carried
interest and we don't want to
um and you know this is Greenfield for
uh a person can gain access to our
public-private uh Arc Venture fund
public private we've done it that way
and and it'll it'll evolve to 75 percent
private 25 public because we want
liquidity for quarterly withdrawals just
like retab quarterly withdrawals up to
five percent of nav that's what we will
have and we'll we need that public
market liquidity in order to provide
that so it's a much better vehicle than
Venture Capital uh first of all you're
you're not locked locked up for seven to
ten years you can can get in with five
hundred dollars you can inflow daily or
average in if you want
and really what we're trying to do here
is democratize Venture Capital investing
and we want to uh we want to increase
the allocation of capital
to private companies which are where the
Innovation starts of course so it's
interesting to talk about this model and
this may be a little bit in the weeds
but I think it's an important point is
that a traditional Venture Capital fund
is completely a liquid right I manage a
number of different Venture Capital
funds and those investors who put the
capital in don't get Capital back until
there is either a company that goes
public or is acquired and there's uh
profits that are generated for you all
you have 75 percent that eventually will
be in the illiquid Venture Capital uh
Investments together 25 you're putting
those into public companies that have an
innovation focus and that's where you're
able to generate the quarterly
withdrawals yes that's right and um and
I'd also like to say in the public
markets what's happened and I'm on my
soapbox here so
um we've had this shift towards passive
investing
um because of the tech and Telecom bust
and even more so after the 0809 Meltdown
uh asset managers have been thinking
more about career risk and and business
risk after those two massive
dislocations and so the pendulum shift
towards passive has been extreme I think
it constitutes the most massive
misallocation of capital in history and
the reason I say that and the reason I
started Arc is because we have never
been in a period before where five
Innovation platforms you mentioned them
uh the multi-ohmic sequencing robotics
energy storage artificial intelligence
and blockchain Technology we've never
seen five Innovation platforms evolve at
the same time the closest we've come is
to the early 1900s telephone electricity
and automobile
so the irony here is because of the
Tekken Telecom bust that's how this all
started there is a fear of Technology
there's a new technology early stage
technology there's a fear of volatility
people forget that volatility yet
doesn't feel good on the downside but
boy is it nice on the upside and so we
are trying to
change that pendulum at least be a part
of it shifting back to active management
because there are so many opportunities
and we actually think the risks for
those who are thinking about career and
business risk the risks today we believe
are more in the traditional benchmarks
which represent the traditional World
Order and safety tried as true well if
there are five major platforms evolving
at the same time the most provocative of
which is artificial intelligence the
breakthroughs we're seeing are
astounding us and all we focus on is
innovation we're seeing breakthroughs
today that we did not expect for five to
ten years and finally with chat GPT we
may be well we have captured the
imagination of the general public
but as we're talking to prospective
investors there's still this here like
oh no oh no you know so it's it's a very
interesting time this is not like the
tech and Telecom bubble in fact it's the
opposite the tech and Telecom bubble
happened because of the internet there
was this again capturing the imagination
of the public what the internet wow look
at what this is going to allow and uh
and then investors started throwing
Capital
at eyeballs that was the valuation
metric how many potential eyeballs can
this website Garner in the next five to
ten years so that was too much Capital
chasing too few opportunities too soon
the Technologies were not ready
and even if they were close to ready the
costs were prohibitive so to give you a
couple of examples there
DNA sequencing cost for one person's
genome and forgive me if you've heard
this but it is the most provocative
example here
um it cost in 2003 when the first genome
was pretty much finished we've we've
completed it now it cost 2.7 billion
dollars and took 13 years of computing
power for one person's genome remember
that six billion bits of code
um today it costs two hundred dollars
and uh can take a few hours so we are
all going to have our genomes
um sequenced regularly and we're all
going to have geneticists because I'm
going to go back to those mutations as
we age more mutations occur and we need
to figure those out so that we can edit
them program them out of the system so
the costs are low enough now that's an
example and the Technologies are ready
so if you think about the cloud it
really didn't happen until it was a a
figment of the imagination but it didn't
it didn't happen we didn't have the
technology until AWS uh in 2006 we
didn't have the first really big
breakthrough in AI deep learning until
2012 and really the the
Transformer architecture
um in Ai and until
2017-18 and that's why we now have chat
GPT one of the things that I want people
who are going to watch this later or
hear in attendance to take away is kind
of very specific insights and I think
that you're the perfect person who
you've thought very differently
um obviously about the way that you
structure the funds so doing active
management within the ETF wrapper we
just talked about the venture capital
structure where you have 75 private 25
public but you also have a number of
insights that I think uh it takes a long
time and it takes a lot of experience in
investing to start to identify and so
one of them you mentioned earlier is
this idea of volatility and when most
people hear volatility they get scared
right it has this negative connotation
you don't want volatility
you're mentioning though that maybe
actually volatility is a good thing and
if you can harness the volatility that's
actually where Returns come can you
elaborate a little bit on that yes
um before I go there can I just say one
more thing about the Venture fund this
is your show you say whatever you want
oh thank you well the the
um we're known for our social media and
social marketing strategies we give our
research away happily we are now giving
more and more of our models away
starting with Tesla because they are so
misunderstood and because uh because our
analysts given their domain expertise
have
um uh have been disparaged by the
traditional Asset Management world where
most have mbas we do not want n mbas we
do in terms of managing our business but
in terms of investing uh we don't we
don't want we think domain expertise is
going to be much more important given
what we do so
added to social media and social
marketing
we have now a social distribution
strategy so Titan which is an Andries
and Horowitz funded company is an app
that now is featuring our featuring our
interval fund and what has been
astounding to us is every day no matter
what the market was doing we have had
inflows every day now slow and but sure
and so I I think that the the individual
investor out there
understands in many ways more than a lot
of Institutions how much is changing how
the ground is Shifting underneath our
feet and they don't they're not finding
the companies they want in the
traditional Financial world so
volatility
um yes volatility many people think that
that is
a measure of risk it is not a measure of
risk per se it is it is in one sense in
that it is more a function of
uncertainty
and when we move into a risk-off period
as we've been in for the last 18 months
plus
the time Horizons investor time Horizon
shrink and in fact what I found most
interesting about the last 18 months is
our strategies were very much out of
favor they are coming back into favor
and we can talk about why in a moment
but very much out of favor because of
fears of inflation and interest rates
and the actuality of both of them going
up
long duration assets so very long-term
asset oriented assets are going to be
punished when interest rates go up
especially at the rate they went up over
the last two years we are up I think
somewhere between 18 and 20 fold in
terms of the FED funds rate that has
never happened in history what all also
never happened in history was that the
bond market which was The Refuge for
those
fearing volatility and risk had the
worst performance I think this was true
through the end of the year I know it
was true through the end of uh the third
quarter the worst quarter
in history unless you go back to the
1700s so that was one long duration
asset and that actually has income
associated with it our strategy which
tends not to We tend not to pay
dividends our companies don't they
they're you know they're they're
reinvesting in their companies in order
to
um you know really gain exposure to
exponential growth trajectories which is
what we want them to do so our strategy
is no income we're going to be treated
much worse than uh than bonds
um but
um and so this idea of volatility just
to give you a sense of this the the
realities that we faced and that we want
people investors to understand
pre-covered
as not as we were beginning to
understand what a disaster this was
going to be there was a one month period
where the market depending on the
measure went down 25 to 30 percent just
in one month we were down our Flagship
was down 46 percent more volatile as the
uncertainty kicked up
um then because our Mantra one of them
is is you know Innovation solves
problems why are they selling and of
course uh the reason they were selling
are our our stocks is because our
company's cash flows again as I just
said are not going to the investor right
away they're being reinvested to make
this new world happen and so investors
don't like that and when they when they
have a short term time Horizon they sold
us and I said wait a minute who do you
think is going to solve this covet
problem
um it's it's our companies and our our
we call them at the time genomics
companies were the most punished of all
because many had negative cash flow and
uh not very large cash positions and so
some of them were down 75 to 80 within
one month just to give you a sense of
what we were dealing with then October
of 20 I mean April April of 20 the
market bottoms and from the April of 20
to February of 21. everybody began to
understand yes our companies are going
to develop the vaccine the tests they're
sequencing the virus and so forth uh our
Flagship strategy which has exposure to
genomics was up 360 percent and that was
less than a year and then from February
21 until the bottom in December we were
down almost 80 percent and uh that was
the most extreme experience of my career
and I think it was because of what
happened to interest rates it was so
sharp so sudden and I think we're going
to see the ramification of this for
years but I also think that the market
is beginning to look at interest rates
and inflation crusting
and coming down and if we're right
inflation is going to shock people on
the low side of expectations for two
reasons
um one the the inventory build up out
there because of over ordering around
supply chain is uh coming off but more
important longer term is the in
deflation inherent in Innovation and we
believe now that for example electric
vehicles are up to 10 percent of Total
Auto Sales and electric and Elon Musk is
going to make sure that electric vehicle
prices to continue to come down at
investor day today this week our
analysts were able to understand now how
Elon and team are going to get the Tesla
average Tesla price down from fifty
thousand dollars to twenty five thousand
dollars in the next five years
and traditional gas-powered Autos are
are really going to go by the wayside so
that's just one example so Innovation
cheaper better better solution and uh
will cause a lot of disruption to the
traditional world order so just to give
you a sense of that we believe that
electric vehicle sales will increase
from 7.7 Million last year
to 60 million in 2027 and they will
account for 75 percent or more of Auto
Sales because of the declining prices
and these are better cars from many
different points of view
how do you deal with
um the critics when a fund draws down 80
percent it's not a private fund where
only the LPS know right
um You are uh somewhat similar
um to many people in the Bitcoin or
crypto world who talk about a lot uh
online on the way up you kind of get all
the praise right and everyone thinks
that you're not only very smart but
you're making a lot of money and
investors are flocking to these funds or
these assets
um but then when it turns over as every
Market does and has throughout history
it almost feels like then that reverses
and now you're the bad person right like
oh Kathy you know why did she go and
invest in all these companies even
though maybe a year or two years before
people were praising you and saying how
smart of a strategy it was how do you
deal with uh not only the volatility the
assets but the volatility of
um the public conversation where there's
praise and then critique and then praise
and then critique back and forth back
and forth
you're right so uh
where where I feel like we're very
similar on that topic over the last 18
months
right so in February of 21 we could do
no wrong no wrong and I prepared the
team I said this is not the real world
there is going to be another side
uh don't take yourselves too seriously
or any of this too seriously take our
investing and our research seriously but
do not take the praise out there to
heart and assume that uh we're brilliant
and uh we can do no wrong
um and so they were prepared for the
first installment but for you know you
know to this last year to be down as
much even more
um was uh it was a very interesting time
for us and much like in the crypto World
um what uh what gave us the courage of
our conviction and you know basically
shielded us from from the critics in
some way was our research and the
breakthroughs that were happening faster
not slower faster you know when times
are tough
Innovation actually gains more traction
faster better cheaper more creative more
productive and so that's the irony here
we saw the traction that Innovation was
getting as the prices were coming down
and so what was happening was and of
course we look at we have a five-year
investment time Horizon our valuations
on our five-year forecast
crashed and what I began to say in the
media I'd say as well
I I consider what we're doing now if you
give us a five-year investment time
Horizon
we we have a deep value strategy and of
course this drives the value guys crazy
because who benefited during this last
period was value and here we are saying
well no no no no no I look at Energy
prices for example
the energy price after Russia invaded
Ukraine peaked at 130 dollars the oil
price below the 147 in 08 which was the
secular Peak and it has not been able to
get back there again it's at 75 80 and
we've been saying that we believe the
demand for oil and this is one of the if
you did not own oil last year as a value
investor oil I think was up 60 that the
sector reaching for all-time highs as
the oil price was coming down very
unusual circumstance uh and so what
we're saying and we put it in our big
Ideas 2023. Big Ideas 2023 is on our
website arc-invest.com and you'll find
in there in our autonomous Mobility
section an oil demand chart and if we're
right on both electric and autonomous
oil demand which is about a hundred
million uh barrels per day now and has
been we actually think it's been peaking
for the last few years it got hit during
covid isn't quite back to where it was
we think we're in the peaking process
secular peak in demand and we think that
by
2020 no this would be 2030
that oil demand will be down 30 million
barrels now wow oil demand except for
recessions has has gone down a little
bit during recessions but has been in a
secular uptrend for you know 70 80 90
years what are the ramifications of
something like that right so when you
talk about a secular peak in 2008 at 147
you all believe that there will still be
volatility to the oil price but
basically the demand for barrels will
continue to go down there are Financial
ramifications obviously some people who
can stomach the volatility will just
short it if they believe in that thesis
and they potentially could make money
but the world runs on oil right and
there's a lot of geopolitical
um posturing and kind of chest that gets
played around oil we've even seen the
United States have to go and visit other
countries and say hey uh you want to
release some of that oil to us
um
what is some of the ramifications or do
you guys not care what the ramifications
are because you say hey look we're
Financial investors we have a thesis on
the peak in oil demand and if we get
that right our investments will do well
everything else is kind of outside of
our purview or our Focus
um well first of all I'll set this up by
saying that we think the oil price is
going to be extremely volatile and the
reason is we've seen some of this
already combination of ESG and
environmental concerns generally oil
companies pull back on investing which
is one reason the oil price did get back
to 130. now
this will also Drive the value investors
I apologize if some of you are here uh
crazy but if you look back at whale oil
remember that was our primary source of
energy you know light in in the day
what you saw when it was clear with the
oil Discovery breakthroughs that oil was
going to displace uh whale oil
what you saw was a massive increase in
volatility because companies basically
said all right game over I'm not
investing in this anymore and until the
transition was complete there was still
a dependence of course on whale oil we
think the same thing is going to be true
here now all Commodities are priced at
the margin and so the expectation out
there right now in terms of what
actually is being produced is that oil
the price is going to continue to move
up over time
and demand demand is going to move up
oil price will come back
uh if we're right uh I just mentioned
the oil price will be very volatile the
valuations of these stocks will continue
to come down that's how you will see it
reflected in the market uh and um in
terms of the ramifications generally
this is going to be a massive tax cut
for the consumer and businesses
accepting energy business
which is hugely positive for the world
it is also going to from a geopolitical
point of view it's going you know the
Middle East had has had still has a lot
of Economic and political power because
of its oil position that is going to
change and so what we have to worry
about
is as as Energy prices oil prices come
down you know how will they try and
change the subject you know we've what
we're watching what Saudi Arabia and UAE
are doing they're both shifting they
understand they I mean they may not
agree completely with our thesis but
they know they have to diversify so
they're both diversifying into
Innovation actually UAE
um uh probably more methodically I would
say than uh than Saudi Arabia it's
interesting this week yesterday there
was an article in the Wall Street
Journal about the UAE not leaving OPEC
and I'm saying
man this is really interesting whenever
Saudi Arabia and the UAE disagree the
oil price is on the threshold of
collapsing
um why is that
because Saudi Arabia has the the highest
reserves of oil
and it is in Saudi Arabia's interest to
control
the price don't let don't let it go too
high because you want the demand to be
sustained don't let it go too low
because you can't fund your finances
UAE some parts of the UAE are hardly
dependent on Dubai for example is only
five percent dependent on uh oil so they
don't have exactly the same incentives
in fact their incentives probably are to
increase production now to maximize if
we're right on what's Happening Here and
I think they they believe we're right
than it is in their interest if they can
to maximize their oil production now you
know if Saudi Arabia is going to be the
offset so the last I've seen that happen
a few times and each time there's been a
rift the oil prices come down
dramatically so UAE came out and and
denied it but hey why are there smoke
sometimes or thou dust protest too much
you know we've been here so we'll see
what happens we'll see what happens I
want to talk about Bitcoin and the
cryptocurrency market uh you all were
one of the first or the first
um you know kind of traditional Wall
Street asset management firm uh not only
to openly talk about it and uh highlight
your maybe cautious optimism towards the
asset but also to actually buy uh
Bitcoin specifically
um when you look back maybe we can start
with like we're now maybe eight nine
years into this journey for you
um other than being able to say you were
right what else would you kind of look
back and say there were lessons along
the way that you've taken in uh in kind
of embracing Bitcoin and the rest of
cryptocurrency so early you know I think
one of uh one of the things that I love
about Bitcoin
um
in particular is my economics background
matters and so here are all of these
developers and
young people very interested in the
space and like I want to learn from them
and they want to learn from me so it's a
really it's been fun so much I mean it's
brought in probably all of all of my
expertise from an investing point of
view and from an economic point of view
and and it's wonderful you know that
this can bridge that Gap you know the
economics and the technology uh yeah in
the early days so we gained we did we
started our research when we were at
Alliance Bernstein first that was 2011.
uh I founded Arc 2014 did the research
and in fact when we first broke out the
five major Innovation platforms we did
not have ai and and blockchain uh there
we had instead what we called we had
that in mind those in mind but we had
Next Generation internet and as we
started doing our Bitcoin research I
brought in art laugher
it was a very well-known Economist known
for fiscal policy Theory as well as
monetary policy Theory and he agreed to
collaborate and
I I when he said this is what I've been
looking for ever since we went off the
gold exchange standard in 1971 a
rules-based Global monetary system
and I said oh wow how big could this be
and it was only a six billion dollar
a net we called it Network value at the
time market cap
um he said well how big is the U.S
monetary base
and I I said well it's four and a half
trillion and now of course it's 8
trillion seven and a half eight trillion
uh he said well there you go and so I
bought personally you know and
that's a big number art and in fact in
fact Chris bernisky was our Analyst at
the time
and
um we we there was no vehicle to put it
in our funds gbtc was just coming of age
and we were doing our due diligence and
so I bought
um a hundred thousand dollars worth just
personally and Chris became like here I
am the portfolio manager and and it was
his research that moved me to do this
and like it was so early and and so he
doubled down on his research
it was bad if your boss loses money
because you're a research right
um but and and then of course uh you
know the rest is history I I guess where
it is it 300 billion ish no uh and as
and and many people know that we think
that's 300 billion in in market cap or
network value
um at twenty four thousand dollars and
we have him Big Ideas again our uh
forecast for
2027 I think is
um 600 around 650 000 and beyond that
1.5 million let's say that again
in the Big Ideas resources you guys
published what are the uh two numbers
the two numbers uh are we have our base
case
is roughly 650 000 for 2027. now that
has come down we were using a million
plus four or five years out but because
we've had the the debacles associated
with centralized opaque institutions as
opposed to decentralized and transparent
um institutions are are going to hold
back a little bit but we still think uh
that the the million plus is right
um in our bull case and you can see how
we build our case and and look at the
assumptions how much institutional
involvement and so forth very
conservative assumptions and our
conviction actually has grown through
this year grown through this past year
because
FTX Celsius 3ac uh Voyager all of these
were centralized opaque institutions
they they went bust and even the
centralized regulated institutions now
we're looking at Genesis
probably bankruptcy yes silvergate
these are regulated
and they're good but again they're much
more centralized and okay this is
interesting
um as many people know I've gone around
the world I've talked to all kinds of
different people and I would say the
number one topic other than like what is
it that people want to speak about when
they come from the traditional world is
it's unregulated right and there's
something about regulation and uh these
individuals usually come from a
perspective of like oh the government
will regulate it out of existence the
government will ban or outlaw ownership
the government won't allow this to occur
but your point I think is Bitcoin as an
asset it's a inanimate object right no
different than like let's say the US
dollar and we don't regulate the dollar
we regulate the companies and
individuals who traffic in dollars right
or use dollars
but there's all these companies in and
around Bitcoin or cryptocurrencies that
have been regulated and we see maybe in
a a really optimistic lens stress on
them all the way to failure of these
businesses
can regulation actually stop some of
this or is regulation in many cases it
can solve some of the things in the
periphery but we should expect regulated
businesses to be just as much at risk as
you know some of the unregulated
businesses and we can't really rely on
that regulation as like this crutch
because it seems like most people would
say it was a regulated business
then we shouldn't be seeing some of the
things that we're seeing
right well uh Bitcoin came out of 0809
right and look at all the regulated uh
companies that went under then and all
of the counterparty risk that nobody
understood you know and all of the
paperwork that had not been done uh so
you know I do think about what you're
saying I I think
I don't think we worry about the
Innovation that is leaving the US and
moving to other countries who are much
more friendly the UK I think is and
Europe generally from a regulatory point
of view has
um has has much more of a solution more
clarity than the US
and so but I think the American DNA is
such and we see it in how Regulators are
going this far but you know and the most
interesting one to me now consider the
source we own it I want to be very
everything that we've spoken about today
you should assume one of the two of us
owners right right right so
so coinbase
now I'm listening to The Regulators
and they're saying well if it looks like
a security and it walks like a security
and it quacks like a security then it's
a security and we will enforce the
insecurities laws that's what the SEC
does
and I'm thinking well
coinbase
had to go through the SEC
they had to they had to issue an S1
highly regulated
they had a a lot of tokens that now the
SEC is questioning as Securities well
has the definition of its security
change since coinbase went public in
2001 and went public around the time
that Gary Gensler came in so maybe
that's where the disconnect is Gary
Gensler is much more of an enforcer I
don't know but the definition of a
security should not have changed and if
they didn't think these should have been
on coinbase's platform
if then they shouldn't have let them go
through so this is fascinating because
in politics uh as some of the guests
later today will talk about this idea of
changing your mind is almost uh
demonized or condemned and you hear
terms like flip-flopper and all of that
in investing it's actually embraced by
the best investors and so if you can
change your mind when you receive new
information uh it's seen as a sign of
intelligence
Regulators kind of sit in between those
two groups it's a little bit of politics
and government it's a little bit of
investment in markets how should we look
at them and their ability to change
their mind like is that something that
we should look at is like that's a good
thing that they're doing or does it make
it so hard to invest in a market if a
regulator later can change their mind
right and I'm almost using this as the
example of they just come out and said
hey we got it wrong before now we
believe this
is that a good or bad thing
I I think I think what it is is a
process of iterating to the right answer
and it's very messy so if you look at
how derivatives evolved in the market
was very messy they had to put in place
um not a completely new regulatory
structure but they had to uh they they
had to bring the cftc into the
discussion and we got a whole bunch of
new guidelines and rules right so I
think that's where we're going with this
new asset class which we really do we
believe it's a new asset class I know
that but I know there are securities
associated with the new asset class so
let's just be clear
um you know Bitcoin you've told us is
not a security great uh coinbase clearly
is a security and it has on top of it
assets that could be a new asset class
so I think we're iterating it's been
very messy uh even this a concept of
staking I I don't know if you saw Gary
gensler's video where he said no I'm not
talking about steak
s-t-e-k-e-a-k he's trying to you know
make this very
um he's trying to be approachable and
I'm talking about s-t-a-k-e and and then
you look at
um you look at uh okay the one the one
that paxos basically said it uh it would
stop uh staking there's a couple of them
correct I think Kraken said it and
practice as well yeah
um well uh coinbase has a staking
service but it is a utility not a
security so again we're iterating and it
is interesting to watch the SEC try to
figure this out you're right that that
is a service it's a technology here it's
a security here and it's like it's
complicated right I just want it to be
uh noted that Kathy and the SEC both use
videos to share information so you guys
may be more similar than you think
um one of the last things I want to talk
about is uh finding ideas and you and I
have talked in the past about
um there are some ideas that somebody
sitting on Wall Street May pontificate
on do some Googling start some research
and eventually come to a conclusion that
ends up being a great investment idea
there's also a long list of ideas both
inside of investment firms consulting
firms I'm sure there's a lawyer
somewhere in the law firm who's got a
horrible idea right and there's really
really long ideas a list of ideas that
end up not being good Investments
because you just know the world and the
reality that you're in
there are areas though that I think you
all look at things like whether it's
gambling and betting whether it's the
porn industry or others that seem to be
at the Forefront of using some of the
technology so they're not necessarily
creating it but can you talk a little
bit as to how you think about where to
look for these ideas and then how do you
evaluate when you see some of these kind
of Fringe Industries doing something is
that actually an Innovative idea and
technology or is that something that
maybe a fad today and is going to
eventually go away
so it's interesting
um and this really I learned through the
internet
um the the the the the earliest users
um were the porn industry and gaming and
um and they became Avid users very
quickly right
um
and that is that is what makes
Innovation difficult in in terms of
investing because he here I I was a I
was a portfolio manager at the time and
I was attracted to this technology
called the early 90s the internet and
there were all these articles out there
about what a bed of criminal activity it
was so here's a fairly young portfolio
manager I'm trying to make my way in
contribute to the team and I'm coming in
with this idea that has porn and and and
betting and uh thank God six sigalis and
God bless him I just went to his
memorial service this past week he gave
me the biggest breaks of my career he
believed in me he uh he kind of knew
that what I was saying was right that
you know often the earliest adopters are
in these two areas and actually you
should look at what they are using and
and in terms of technology and how
they're using it to actually learn some
lessons about where the world's going to
go the other thing they they do is they
Grease the skids in terms of you know
making or helping technology helping
those evolving the technology perfect it
right so we we you know a rights law is
all is centered on unit growth so
Moore's Law is centered on on time so
every 18 months to two years rights law
is centered on units so the more
something is used
uh the faster the cost will come down
right and uh so those early users are
critical to jump starting technology so
I actually look at what their what
technologies they're using yeah just to
see if I'm uh you know what what what
else is coming down the pipe the last
thing I want to talk to you about
um
you're an independent thinker there's
many conversations we've had there's
many things I've seen you say publicly
where uh I judge the independence of
your thought on the reaction that people
have
um and as many people can just Google
Arc or Kathy Wood right now there's a
lot of people who are saying what are
they talking about right this is crazy
town
um but if you go a little bit further
back and maybe search in 2014 2015 2016
there was a lot of the same people
saying that about you guys then and uh
it appears that over a long period of
time you guys have been right about a
lot of things when people questioned
what you were doing
you remain so steadfast in the ability
to continue to think independently and
especially do it when there's a lot of
folks trying to convince you that you're
either wrong uh maybe you shouldn't do
that or that there's an easier path to
just simply become a value investor or
you know buy indexes and why do you have
to do all this work how do you think
about just we are independent thinkers
and this is the way to kind of continue
to think independently and not succumb
to the consensus law
you know the the criticism out there
um you know we're we don't have a not
invented here there is sometimes people
pick up on something that we have missed
that's why we're publishing our models
more and more I find that to be a very
effective
um uh battle test of of our assumptions
and so forth
um but in terms of keeping our focus on
Innovation which is again because of the
Innovation platforms evolving we have
just to give you here's what keeps me
focused if you look today at how at the
how the market values truly disruptive
innovation in the marketplace both
private and public it's about 13
trillion dollars so a little more than
10 percent of the total Equity market
cap we think that's going to 200
trillion more than 200 trillion by 2030
this is in Big Ideas you can you can see
the building blocks that's a 40 compound
annual rate of return now if our if our
Technologies are doing that hopefully
we're doing something better picking the
right companies and so forth and we will
do better
I cannot say that we will deliver that
compliance will not let us or north of
that but as our research as we see the
research breakthroughs happening at a
faster and faster rate and we don't see
the traditional World focusing on on
these we just know the opportunity is
that much bigger so I learned very early
on in my career it was economics it was
the early 80s and inflation and interest
rates were in the mid teens and I came
in again young and art Laffer trained I
felt like I knew how the world worked
and said inflation and interest rates
are coming down for this that and the
other reason that was such a
controversial call you had the great
powers on Wall Street at the time and
Milton Friedman you had Henry Kaufman
and Al wozlauer who were the doctors of
death and doom that's just how bad
things were in terms of inflation and
interest rates and Milton Friedman
basically saying get used to it
inflation is embedded in the system at a
double-digit rate and so the whole world
was moving in that direction and here we
were this little voice and I mean really
little who was going to pay attention to
me and we were writing again there were
no computers at the time there was you
know there was so I wrote a 20-page
quarterly letter to our clients mostly
Pension funds and it became as inflation
and interest rates were coming down
people wanted to know why this was
happening so there's no no no no no no
then there's evidence that it is and
then people look and say why is this
happening and so it's the same with
innovation no no no no no the old way of
the world is the right way no no no no
no no and yet that yet the evidence is
moving
incontrovertibly in the other direction
it's the evidence that keeps us sane and
actually is a great Shield against all
of the criticism and we're just we're
and one of the reasons we've put our
research out there and our models out
there is we're saying hey there is so
much happening right now
that is going to be highly disruptive
to not only investors but your personal
lives and it is really important that
you get on the right side of change and
it's one reason we moved to Saint Pete
we'd like to use Saint Pete as a place
to Showcase over time sort of like
Disney's old Carousel of Progress which
hasn't changed since the 60s
we'd like to show people how their lives
are going to change and our research is
the first way of doing it but we have
other ideas as well I love it ladies and
gentlemen Kathy Wood
thank you
thank you thank you so much of course